die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara
halweg guten Abend und Willkommen an
meiner Seite ist Norbert Lehmann für den
Sport ein schön guten abenag von mir und
das sind die Nachrichtenthemen dieses 2
Januars keine Entspannung in den
Hochwassergebieten Deiche sind extrem
aufgeweicht in einigen Flüssen steigen
wieder die
Pegelstände massive Angriffswelle auf
die Ukraine Russland bombardiert zu
Beginn des Jahr vor allem die Hauptstadt
Kiev Kollision bei Landung am Flughafen
in Tokio können sich mehr als 370
Passagiere aus einem brennenden Airbus
retten den Dauerregen können die
Menschen in den Hochwassergebieten
überhaupt nicht brauchen die Deiche
weichen noch mehr auf möglicherweise
müssen noch mehr Leute evakuiert werden
und nach der Prognose des Wetterdienstes
soll es noch bis Donnerstag kräftig
regnen Warnungen vor schwerem Hochwasser
gibt es aktuell für viele Gebiete etwa
in Bayern und Sachsen Anhalt weiterhin
angespannt ist auch die Situation in
Niedersachsen an Flüssen wie Leine aller
und Hunte mehr jetzt von Scarlet
Sternberg in einigen Regionen
Niedersachsens bleibt die Hochwasserlage
kritisch ein sogenanntes großes
Hochwasser das also bewohnte Gebiete
mitüberflutet gilt als selten zahlreiche
Pegelstände der Flüsse sind weiterin
über der höchsten Meldestufe hier muss
die deichwehr in großem Umfang
eingesetzt werden betroffen sind vor
allem die Hunte die Leine und die aller
Marianne von holdolt hatte 30 Jahre kein
Wasser in ihrem Friseursalon nahe der
aller dieses Mal traf es
sie das ist Friseurgeschäft od es war
eins es steht nichts mehr wie es war es
ist ja alles durcheinander und wir
mussten alles hochstellen weil das
Wasser hier ja 10 cm hoch stand um das
zu vermeiden sind Feuerwehr und THW im
Dauereinsatz auch in Liliental bei
Bremen keine Entwarnung viele Häuser
sind durch das Wasser abgeschnitten noch
dürfen die Anwohner nicht zurück völlig
aufgeweicht ist der Deich groß die Sorge
dass er brechen kann der Deich das
Bauwerk steht immer noch wirklich satt
im Wasser der Druck ist etwas weniger
geworden von daher gehen wir momentan
von einer geringeren Gefährdungslage aus
nichtsdestotrotz sobald die Pegel wieder
etwas steigen müssen wir aufpassen was
passiert rund 100000 Helfer
Niedersachsen kämpfen die Fluten gut
aufgestellt ist Deutschland aber nicht
gut genug kritisiert die Präsidentin des
Deutschen Roten Kreuzes wir brauchen
mehr finanzielles Engagement des Bundes
im Bereich des bundesweiten
Bevölkerungsschutzes und das hat gerade
diese Katastrophe jetzt im
hochwasserbereich im Norden unseres
Landes deutlich gezeigt für morgen sind
weiterhin für den Nordwesten Regenfälle
vorhergesagt und die alles entscheidende
Frage bleibt werden die deicher halalten
Fabian Köhler ist in Winsen an der Aller
Fabian wie ist die Lage und wie ist das
Wetter na ja das Wetter aktuell es
regnet ich weiß nicht ob man es sehen
kann aber es regnet seit heute
Nachmittag ziemlich heftig muss man
sagen und das was man hier hinter mir in
den Scheinwerfern sieht und was sich
auch im Wasser spiegelt das ist das TAW
das TAW ist hier in der Siedlung in der
Nähe von Winsen seit gestern im Einsatz
sie versuchen hier die Straße wieder
freiupumpen und den Anwohnern hier links
und rechts von dieser Straße bringt ist
wirklich etwas wie sie mir auch
berichtet haben das heißt seitdem das
TAW das Wasser hier abpumpt geht auch
hier das Wasser wirklich ein bisschen
zurück das Problem ist jetzt das
nachdrückende Grundwasser von der aller
aus diesem Gebiet die aller ist rund 300
m von hier entfernt im Moment noch
hinter den Deichen und das ist auch gut
so die Deiche mussten auch hier an
einigen Stellen schon gefflickt werden
und die Anwohner hier ringsherum mussten
sich teilweise selber helfen hier dieses
Haus was man so ein bisschen in der
Beleuchtung erahnen kann die haben in
den letzten Tagen zwischen den Jahren
säckeweise Rindenmulch und spelsand
geholt um einfach Ihr Haus zu schützen
denn hätten sie diesen Wall nicht
errichtet dann wäre das Wasser auch bei
ihnen in die Wohnräume gelaufen so
konnten sie aber durch ihren
selbstgebauten Deich wirklich ihr habp
und gut erstmal retten und jetzt ist
wirklich die spannende Frage was kommt
an Regen in der Nacht in den nächsten
Stunden hier und vor allen Dingen im
Harz der sich 100 km entfernt befindet
noch runter und dann wird sich erst
zeigen in den nächsten 2 D Tagen wie
viel Wasser wirklich die Flüsse hier
noch runterfließt danke schön für diese
Eindrücke Fabian Köhler war
das
die Menschen in der Ukraine haben
furchtbare Tage und Nächte hinter sich
seit Freitag wird das Land von einer
neuen russischen Angriffswelle überzogen
die Verbündeten im Westen müssten jetzt
schnell zusätzliche Waffen liefern
fordert der ukrainische Außenminister
kleba neben der Großstadt harkiv im
Osten gab es auch in der Hauptstadt Kiev
mehrere heftige Explosionen dabei sollen
fünf Menschen getötet und mehr als 90
verletzt worden sein Christoph desterell
berichtet
vorsichtshalber in Deckung gehen viele
Kief entscheiden sich so an diesem
Morgen Explosionen hatten sie aus dem
Schlaf gerissen wie lebensrettend ihre
Flucht in die Metro vielleicht war zeigt
sich oben dort Steuern nach einer ersten
drohenwelle dutzende Marschflugkörper
ihre Ziele an Feuer brechen aus mitten
in der Stadt werden riesige Krater in
den Boden gerissen und auch Wohnhäuser
getroffen wir wollten gerade frühstücken
und dann auf die Arbeit als alles in die
Luft flog ich beugte mich nach vor um
mir die Schuhe zu binden als
Fensterscheiben über meinen Kopf
sausten wie grausam all das ist und
wofür denn frage ich
sie Helfer Bergen Verletzte aus den
Trümmern leisten Erste Hilfe noch auf
der Straße bei laufendem Luftalarm
stundenlang gehen die Sirenen in Kiev
und anderen
Städten wieder haben die russischen
Unmenschen uns attackiert mit fast 100
Raketen verschieden Art davon konnten
wir Abfangen der Welt sage ich danke an
jeden der uns militärisch geholfen hat
jedes einzelne Abwehrsystem hat
mindestens hunderte Leben
gerettet wieso Russland ausgerechnet
jetzt wieder massiv Zivilisten angreift
um die Feiertage symbolisch besonders
wirksam vermuten Beobachter vor allem
aber aus einem einfachen Kalkül heraus
Russland produziert etwa 100 Fernwaffen
pro Monat und man hat sich diese z im
Oktober November aufgespart um massive
Angriffe durchzuführen die Rechnung
dahinter ist dass desto höher die Anzahl
der angreifenden Raketen desto größer
die Chance für individuelle Flugkörper
die ukrainische Flugabwehr zu
durchdringen auch in chgif geht die
zynische Rechnung auf eine tote viele
Verletzte wohl alles Zivilisten Russland
erklärt man habe nur militärische
Anlagen anvisiert und meldet all diese
Ziele wurden
zerstört fragen wir unsere Reporterin
Alisa jung die seit Tagen diesen neue
Angriffswelle in der Ukraine miterlebt
wie war das in Kiev
heute es war schon wieder eine
schlaflose Nacht für die Menschen hier
in Kiev aber eben auch in hakiv eine
Nacht voller Angst und dann am nächsten
Morgen heftige Detonationen und wenn man
hier in der Stadt unterwegs ist sieht
man dann auch was das Ausmaß des Ganzen
ist ein riesiger Krater unter anderem in
der Stadt beschädigte Wohngebäude die
zivile Infrastruktur wurde getroffen mit
Menschen gesprochen die eben dort
getroffen worden sind im am Morgen in
ihren Wohnhäusern die dort Schutz
gesucht haben im Korridor die sagen die
große Furcht davor haben das war nicht
die letzte Nacht also dass diese
Angriffswelle weiter geht und die
außerdem auch sagen wo sollen wir hin
wir sind wir zu Hause sind wir auf dem
Weg zur Arbeit sind wir in einem caff
sind wir auf offener Straße es gibt
keinen sicheren Ort mehr diesen Satz
haben wir in den letzten Tagen häufig
gehört es ist die große Angst der
Menschen dass diese Intensität dieser
russischen Luftangriffe auch in den
nächsten Tagen weitergeht Alisa jung
live aus kie vielen
Dank zur Lage in der Ukraine gibt es
auch ein ZDF heute live zu sehen um
19:30 Uhr in unserer App und auf unseren
Social Media
kanäl bei einem mutmaßlichen
israelischen Drohnenangriff im Libanon
ist ein hochrangiger hamasführer mit
seinen Leibwächtern getötet worden salch
al-aruri sei bei dem Angriff auf ein
hamasbüro in Beirut ums Leben gekommen
meldeten am Abend libanesische Medien
die Terrororganisation bestätigte
inzwischen seinen Tod al-aruri war einer
der Gründer des militärischen arms der
Hamas Israel hat den Angriff bisher
nicht bestätigt Henriette de mier in Tel
Aviv welche Rolle spielte aruri in der
Hamas und was bedeutet sein
Tod salch alarori gilt als Symbolfigur
der Hamas er ist einer von drei
führenden Köpfen auf ihn war ein
Kopfgeld ausgesetzt von 5 Millionen
Dollar er das meldet die Hisbollah und
auch die Hamas ist getötet worden das
israelische Militär sie sagten es will
das bisher nicht bestätigen das
kriegskabinett tagt im Moment auch wie
damit weiter umzugehen ist was wir
wissen ist es hat eine Explosion mit
Toten in Beirut gegeben
vor Wochen hatte der Hisbollah Chef
nasralla angekündigt wenn es Angriffe
auf libanesischem Gebiet geben würde
dann würde die
Antwort prompt kommen und das heißt auch
dass es möglich sein kann dass der Krieg
damit an eine neue Eskalationsstufe
Gerät wenn die hisbolla sich jetzt
einschaltet danke für diese Einschätzung
aus Tel Aviv danke Henriette de mier
nach Japan dort wird nach und nach das
Ausmaß des schweren Erdbebens sichtbar
die Zahl der Toten ist auf mindestens 55
gestiegen das Erdbeben der Stärke 7,6
ereignete sich am Neujahrstag sein
Epizentrum lag in der Region noto
besonders betroffen die Stadt wajima die
Schäden sind massiv zerstörte Straßen
und hunderte Nachbeben erschweren die
Suche nach weiteren Opfern Elisabeth
Schmidt Bilder wie aus einem Albtraum
mehrstöckige Gebäude mühelos von der
Naturgewalt auf die Seite geworfen
tausende Häuser komplett zerstört
Stromleitungen bersten immer wieder
brechen Feuer aus Straßen s unpassierbar
geworden alles was miiki Kobayashi der
Verwüstung im Moment entgegenzusetzen
hat sind Schaufel und Besen ohnmächtig
fühlt sie sich sagt
sie alles ist heruntergefallen die Wand
ist eingestürzt und man kann bis zum
nächsten Zimmer durchsehen ich glaube
nicht dass wir hier noch leben
können ein paar Kilometer weit ein
Hilferuf mit Klappstühlen haben Anwohner
das Wort SOS gebildet noch immer liegen
Menschen unter Gebäuden
begraben im Moment wissen wir von
mindestens 120 Personen die noch auf
Rettung
warten Soldaten treffen erst am
Vormittag im Erdbebengebiet ein die
Betroffenen Präfekturen mussten diese
Hilfe erst offiziell in Tokio beantragen
Bürokratie as usual in einer
Ausnahmesituation einige Gemeinden
melden dass Hilfsgüter knapp werden
Schlange stehen für Essen und
Trinkwasser viele Orts sind
Wasserleitungen zerstört Regierungschef
versucht zu
beschwichtigen wir bemühen uns seit
gestern nach Kräften Informationen zu
sammeln aber viele Straßen sind
blockiert für die Retter ist es äußerst
schwierig noch immer gibt es Nachbeben
den Menschen an Japans Westküste steht
eine weitere bange Nacht bevor und am
Flughafen in Toko kam es zu einem
Flammeninferno eine große
Passagiermaschine prallte mit mit einem
Flieger zusammen der Hilfsmaterial in
die Erdbebengebiete bringen sollte fünf
Menschen starben aber alle
379 Insassen der Japan Airlines konnten
noch rechtzeitig aus der brennenden
Maschine geholt werden Markus tübller
berichtet es ist kurz vor 18 Uhr als der
Inlandsflug aus schitosee als Feuerball
über die Landebahn in Tokio schießt an
Bord
367 Passagiere und 12
Besatzungsmitglieder in der Kabine steht
bereits der Rauch als der Flieger
endlich steht und doch kommen alle
Insassen raus die Rettung gelingt aus
verschiedenen Gründen zum einen die hohe
Disziplin der Besatzung und der
Passagiere auch bei der Evakuierung und
zum anderen die neuen Werkstoffe die
neuen Materialien die in diesem neuen
Flugzeugtyp A350 verbaut sind die
offenbar wir heute auch gesehen haben
sehr viel langsamer in großem Maße
beginnen zu brennen was die Zeit erhöht
für die Evakuierung die Feuerwehr kämpft
gegen die Flammen kann aber nicht
verhindern dass das Feuer den Airbus
nach und nach
zerstört Auslöser für dieses Unglück war
ein Zusammenstoß mit einem anderen
Flugzeug das auf dem Rollfeld stand eine
Maschine der Küstenwache mit Hilfsgütern
für die Erdbebenregion der Pilot
überlebt aber fünf Besatzungsmitglieder
sterben doch angesichts dieser Bilder
zeigt sich dass Japan an einer deutlich
größeren Katastrophe vorbeigeschrabt
ist zurück nach Deutschland die
Mitglieder Zahl der AFD ist stark
gestiegen obwohl sie inzwischen in drei
Bundesländern als gesichert
rechtsextremistisch eingestuft wird nach
Angaben der Partei hat sie zurzeit rund
40.100 Mitglieder 37% mehr als vor einem
Jahr zum Vergleich SPD oder CDU haben
jeweils mehr als 370 000
Mitglieder in Deutschland waren im
vergangenen Jahr so viele Menschen
erwerbstätig wie nie seit der
Wiedervereinigung trotz der
Konjunkturflaute beschäftigt waren im
Schnitt
45,9 Millionen Menschen laut
statistischenem Bundesamt waren das 0,7%
mehr als im bisherigen Rekordjahr
2022 neue Jobs entstanden vor allem im
Dienstleistungsbereich eine Ursache war
die Zuwanderung von Arbeitskräften auch
bei der inländischen Bevölkerung waren
mehr Menschen
erwerbstätig im Fernverkehr der
Deutschen Bahn stockt es immer wieder
2023 kam fast jeder dritte Fahrgast
deutlich zu spät an sein Ziel das liegt
vor allem am maroden Schienennetz sagt
die Bahn und beginnt jetzt mit der
Generalsanierung bis 2030 sollen
insgesamt 4000 Schienenkilometer auf 40
Streckenabschnitten rund erneuert werden
zuerst kommt die Strecke
frankfurtmannheim dran die sogenannte
Riedbahn Peter Wagner
berichtet die Strecke frankfurtmannheim
ist eine der Haupt lagadern des
deutschen Schienennetzes 300 Züge
Rauschen hier Tag für Tag durch jetzt
wird die sogenannte riebahn gesperrt und
saniert für 3 Wochen und dann ab Juli
noch mal bis zum Jahresende die Fernzüge
nehmen eine Umleitung 150 Busse
transportieren die Fahrgäste im
Regionalverkehr wir beginnen ja ganz
bewusst mit der Sanierung der redbahn
zwischen Frankfurt und Mannheim denn
über diese Strecke führt jede siebte
Reise im Fernverkehr und deswegen werden
unsere Fahrgäste schon nach Abschluss
dieser Sanierung also Ende 2024
bundesweit deutlich spüren dass sich die
Pünktlichkeit im Netz verbessert auf der
74 km langen Strecke kommt alles raus
Gleise Schotter Signale und komplett neu
wieder rein Bahnexperten halten das so
für notwendig allerdings lenke die
generalalsanierung ab vom eigentlichen
Problem es gibt zu wenig
Schienenkilometer für 7 Jahre kann man
immer sagen wir bauen gerade deswegen
erwartte bitte keine Pünktlichkeit von
uns und die Bahn hat eben andere
managementpre sie hat eben äh eine
Überlastung des Netzes die also dadurch
nicht gelöst wird der Fahrgastverband
begrüßt die Sanierungen wünscht aber
bessere Kundeninformation insgesamt
müsse man sich die Schweizer Bahn zum
Vorbild nehmen in der Schweiz hat man
seit Jahrzehnten viermal so viel Geld
pro Einwohner und jah für die Schina
ausgegeben als in Deutschland nicht nur
neue Schienen braucht das Land sondern
auch jede Menge mehr davon damit das
umweltfreundliche System Bahn pünktlich
und attraktiv
wird der Chef des Energiekonzerns Eon
Leonard Birnbaum stimmt die Verbraucher
auf steigende Strom und Gaspreise ein
auch weil der Staat Subventionen für die
Netzbetreiber gestrichen hat es sei
jedenfalls nicht zu erwarten dass die
Energiepreise wieder auf das Niveau von
vor dem ukrainekrieg Fallen sagte er der
Rheinischen Post Oliver deuker
berichtet eigentlich sind die
Energiepreise in den vergangenen Monaten
deutlich gesunken trotzdem müssen viele
Kunden seit dem 11 tiefer in die Tasche
greifen so steigt der Gaspreis um
durchschnittlich etwa 17%. ja wir haben
tatsächlich gewechselt und probiert D
umstellertarif zu bekommen und was
günstigeres zu bekommen das ist ja jetzt
auch möglich wer soll das denn alles
noch bezahlen als Rentner hat man so
wenig Geld was denn soll man nachher im
Dunkeln sitzen oder im kalten na ja
vergleichen ne was ist jetzt mein
Grundtarif und was ist der vertragliche
Tarif ne und dann gucke ich ob das Sinn
macht oder nicht Gas wird teurer weil
die Mehrwertsteuer von 7 auf wieder 19%
steigt erhöht wird auch die CO2 Abgabe
von 30 auf 45 € pro Tonne und ab Januar
fällt die gaspreisbremse Weg eine
vierköpfige Familie wird nun
durchschnittlich 370 € mehr bezahlen als
im Vorjahr branchenexerten raten die
aktuellen politischen Entscheidungen
führen zu deutlich mehr kosten bei
Verbraucherinnen und Verbrauchern
Verträge prüfen und wenn ein
Sparpotenzial vorhanden ist dann auch
wechseln beim Strom sollte es eigentlich
günstiger werden eigentlich doch nun
kann der Staat nicht die angekündigten
5,5 5 Milliarden Euro als Zuschuss für
übertragungsnetzentgelte Zahlen heißt
dass wir sozusagen mehr an den
Netzbetreiber bezahlen müssen und dieses
mehr diesen Betrag müssen wir natürlich
auch an unsere Kunden weitergeben obwohl
die Energie an sich an den Börsen eher
günstiger geworden ist die Mehrkosten
für Energie kommen vor allem dem
Staatshaushalt zugute der mit
milliardenlöchern zu kämpfen
hat jetzt zum Sport vi chanzenournee
Station 3 in Innsbruck lief die
nicht so gut für die deutschen Springer
ja allen voran für den Gesamtführenden
Andreas Wellinger der wurde nur 15
während seine direkten Konkurrenten alle
lieferten die bergiselschanze hat ja
schon in den Vorjahren die deutschen
Träume vom Gesamtsieg platzen lassen
Höhe ge Winde ziehen die Qualifikation
am Bergisel in die Länge der
Gesamtführende dieser Tournee Andreas
Wellinger hat schlechte Bedingungen und
landet schon nach 119hb met der Deutsche
ist aber als 15 der Tageswertung für den
Wettkampf qualifiziert es ist halt eine
Lotterie man kann ein Würfel nehmen und
schauen hat man Glück hat man nicht
Glück aber das gehört dazu es ist zum
Glück heute der qualitag und nicht der
Wettkampftag dann hoffen wir dass die
Bedingung morgen besser sind der beste
heute Innsbruck ist der Sieger des
neujahrspringens anz lanisek aus
Slowenien mit einer Weite von 134 m
Andreas wellingers ärgste Verfolger in
der Gesamtwertung Stefan Kraft aus
Österreich und rioyo Kobayashi aus Japan
landen heute auf den Plätzen 2 und 3 der
Qualifikation morgen im Wettkampf werden
alle fünf deutschen Skispringer dabei
sein ja und die Entscheidung morgen in
innsbrurg live bei uns im ZDF zu sehen
Wintersport schon ab
11:15 uh er ist erst 16 Jahre alt und
der Shootingstar der Darts WM Luke ller
der Engländer gewann gestern Abend sein
viertelfinalpiel gegen den Nordiren
Brandon Dolen souverän mit 5 Z1 heute
Abend geht's gegen seinen Landsmann Rob
Cross um den
Finaleinzug Liverpool hat die
Tabellenführung in der Premier League
ausgebaut 4:2 sie gestern Abend gegen
Trainer Jürgen klop mit doppelten Grund
zur Freude Aufregung nach dem Spiel und
dann ist Klops Abend doch perfekt ehing
wiedergefunden was für ein Glück vorher
viele Chancen Tore aber fallen erst nach
der Pause mosal 49 minute die Führung
Salah gestern überragend gegen Newcastle
mit dem Ausgleich aus dem Nichts dann
Traumkombination Liverpool Jones zur
erneuten Führung in der 74 4 Minuten
später GP mit dem 3:1 new trifft noch
einmal den Schlusspunkt aber setzt Mala
4 Z2 so kann ein Jahr beginnen seine
Erklärung übrigens für den ringverlust
er hätte über Weihnachten 2 Kilo
abgenommen es gibt eine Unwetterwarnung
des Deutschen Wetterdienstes noch bis
Donnerstag droht vor allem in den
Mittelgebirgen ergiebiger Dauerregen
mehr dazu gleich von Katja horneffer :
Uhr begrüßt Sie Christian siers im
heutejournal und hier übernimmt morgen
Mitri Sirin einen schönen Abend noch und
auf
[Musik]
bald nachtalt wer das große ganz im
Blick haben will muss vor allem die
Zusammenhänge verstehen und man muss in
jeder Situation den Überblick behalten
Kompetenz zahlt sich aus auch bei ihrer
Geldanlage Union Investment aus Geld
Zukunft machen
um inform Form zu bleiben ist mein
Fahrrad meine Nummer ein und für gute
Laune ist Lisa meine Nummer ein aber
weil ich immer öfter was vergesse habe
ich mich gefragt hast du auch für dein
Gedächtnis eine Nummer einbonin mit dem
pflanzlichen genkextrakt verbessert die
Durchblutung fördert die Verbindung der
Gehirnzellen und stärkt Gedächtnis und
Konzentration deonin meine Nummer ein
für Gedächtnis und Konzentration höchste
Qualität aus Deutschland zu Risen und
Nebenwirkungen lesen Sie die
Packungsbeilage und fragen Sie Ihre ärz
Ihren Arzt oder in ihre
Apotheke
Leben braucht sen darauf kommt an z Seel
nutri denk daran überall
schne Prospekte
weggeschmissen hole dir deine prospekte
aus deiner Gegend in dein
Handy marktguru ein Klick deine
Prospekte im
[Musik]
Blick
guten Abend und frohes neues Jahr zu den
bisher bereits gefallenen 20 bis 40 l
Regen pro Quadratmeter kommen bis
Donnerstag besonders in den West und
Südwest Staulagen der Mittelgebirge noch
mal bis zu 60 l Regen pro Quadratmeter
dazu das heißt die Wasserstände von
Weser aller Leiner Hase und Hunde werden
wieder ansteigen es wird nicht nur sehr
nass sondern auch sehr windig heute
Nacht erwarten wir an der Küste schwere
sturmböhen und die sturmböhen in
nordrwestfalen beschränken sich nicht
nur auf die Berge das wird also eine
sehr verregnete Nacht und diese Nacht
bleibt auch nach wie vor mild wir
erwarten tiefstemperaturen zwischen 10°
am niederrein und 4° z.B im östlichen
Bayern und auch an der Ostsee die
Höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen dann
zwischen 7° im vogland und an der Ostsee
und 12° im östlichen Bayern oder auch am
oberrein morgen Vormittag kann es
nordöstlich der Elbe noch kräftig
weiterregnen dann git es sehr viele
Wolken und kräftige Schauer vor allen
Dingen in den mit Gebirgen westlich des
Rins ist auch mal ein Gewitter dabei am
ehsten freundlich ist es noch im
Alpenvorland am Donnerstag ernert sich
an diesem Wetter wenig dann dreht der
Wind und es wird von Norden immer kälter
guten
Abend